nilawati and her family have lived in
this house in lawang village in northern
aceh for 12 years it used to belong to
her grandmother
but floods have destroyed most of their
possessions including their wedding
photos
they are trying to clean up what they
can
give them
when the flood starts sometimes we have
to leave at night carrying our children
with us
more than 30 000 people across northern
aceh were affected by floods in early
january
this was nilawati's home just a few
weeks ago almost completely submerged
and not for the first time
communities in north aja experience
flooding every few months
the rain has finally stopped and flood
waters have receded now as many try to
repair their damaged homes and salvage
their possessions they're also looking
for answers
the persistent floods have ruined
people's livelihoods more than half of
the rice grown here was spoiled
what can we do we can't leave this is
our home
environmental groups say deforestation
has made north aj vulnerable to flooding
as logging on higher ground means water
runs downhill and into rivers much
faster
millions of hectares have been cleared
to make way for palm oil plantations and
many trees have also been lost to
illegal logging
we still see plantations popping up
using loopholes to acquire new land
authorities in aceh say the situation
will improve when a new reservoir is
complete
we ask the government for a reservoir to
contain the water we can't stop people
from cutting trees in the forest because
that's how they own a living
people here say the government must do
more to stop logging and help save
vulnerable communities
we don't want the government to come
here during floods and give us instant
noodles and rice we need them to think
of solutions
some say they have lost hope i have
nothing this man says the water took
everything from me
exhausted and overwhelmed these people
know it's only a matter of time before
their homes are flooded once again
jessica washington al jazeera ace